Barry Allen
they call him the fastest man alive he
is not that honor belongs to sue if soon
finds out who you care for he'll take
thumb from you pretty messed up
yeah this is ground zero for pretty much
stuff reverse-flash he's back it's so
much more fun to be bad
up is down black is white do not get
distracted by anything you see along the
way whenever you see everything
No
good luck fixing the universe
hey youtubers it's Charlie so I saw a
buncha guys screaming on Twitter this
morning about new flash footage they
dropped an extended version of the
trailer I've already done a video for so
I'm just gonna focus on the new stuff
there were a couple really cool things
that we haven't seen before the best
stuff is what looks like the TV version
of the cosmic treadmill the true cosmic
treadmill we've seen the treadmill at
STAR Labs in present day but this looks
like it's happening inside eobard
thawne's lab or it might be happening in
present day in someone else's lab that
the reverse-flash has hijacked either
either way it's eobard thawne traveling
through time so it looks like an episode
11 that's the reverse flash episode the
reverse flash returns we're gonna see
more things from his perspective now I
know the timelines a little bit wonky
but in the trailer Cisco's like good
luck fixing the universe so I'm gonna
wait to do more timeline explainers till
after the episode because like the show
will have its own internal logic its own
way of explaining time-travel so it's
not really good to try and explain it
using another shows rules for
time-travel we see more Wally West's
action there been some pictures of him
inside that car so it might be from that
same episode from episode 10 if you guys
didn't know the big villain of that
episode in addition to zoom I don't know
how much zoom is gonna be in the episode
but the new character is actually chief
Terrell from Battlestar and it turns out
he is playing a super deep cut Jay
Garrick enemy from the flash comics from
the Golden Age flash comics called the
turtle he can slow the flow of time as
in moving as slow as a turtle does but
the Golden Age version of the character
was way funnier his explainer is is that
he would use slow deliberate planning to
trick Jay Garrick I can't remember if he
came back into the comics during geoff
johns wally west run or if it was during
mark Wade's run but he got into a lab
accident that allowed him to drain speed
from people around him so that that
might be the explanation that the TV
show goes with so the other really big
thing is Barry is inside zooms prison so
you know like when he has Jesse quick
locked up and he's like your father's
abandoned you give up all hope Barry is
inside that same prison and it looks
like this abandoned building so I'm
wondering if it's gonna be this twisted
version of an earth one structure like
someplace Barry is familiar with on
earth one we have spent a lot of time
talking about differences between earth
one and earth two like you know maybe
there is no reverse-flash on earth two
because of all the changes that zoom is
making it's becoming this flash point
type earth where everything is this
twisted version of the earth that we
know heroes that are normally good or
doing really bad things
what about killer frost and death storm
they're actually supposed to show up in
episode 13 they'll be kind of like the
metahuman Bonnie and Clyde's but it
seems like you're not able to be a
metahuman on earth-2 without running
into zoom at some point it zooms the
most powerful metahuman on earth - I'm
assuming that Superman does not exist on
earth - or Supergirl for that matter I
think part of the reason people really
want it to be Barry's dad John Wesley
Shipp because it'd be a really awesome
call back to the original flash series
like the original flash gets to be the
big villain of one of the seasons of the
flash that'd be awesome but also because
of Star Wars she had the Luke Skywalker
Darth Vader thing that's kind of been
done so I'm not expecting that but then
there's also the Green Arrow of Earth -
if you remember back to that flashback
Harrison wells had he was hearing about
zoom capturing his daughter from her
school on the news when they were also
doing a broadcast about Robert Queen
Oliver's dad being unmasked as the
vigilante of Star City
so like like on earth - Oliver Queen
presumably died when the Queens gambit
went down Robert Queen survived lived on
the island for five years then came back
and became the green arrow but really if
you want to spend all of our theories
out you could just say that he might be
like the Sara in that situation where
she shows up later and they're like oh
my god you didn't die you didn't go down
with the ship that I don't expect them
to do evil Oliver anytime soon they kind
of did that in air of season 3 when he
was supposedly part of the League of
Assassins but let me know in the
comments right now who do you think the
zoom is it has that changed over the
last couple of episodes I feel like
people are coming back from Jay Garrick
a lot of people were like oh yeah I bet
it's Jay Garrick because he's never
around when zooms around but the problem
with that is that when Jay Garrick took
the velocity-6 formula his eyes like the
lightning in his eyes glowed yellow and
it would have glowed blue if he had been
zoom that's another thing too from this
trailer look at this device doesn't that
look like the exact same color as zooms
lightning now I think it's a little more
complicated than that
but I'm wondering what happened to zoom
to make his lightning blue because
usually in the comics the color of the
Lightning is associated with how you got
the Speed Force like you know how you
how your accident went down now the TV
dummy explanation is that they make the
different colors so that you can tell
who is fighting who on screen I know
that sounds kind of stupid but that's
kind of how TV works George Lucas was
asked one time why Darth Vader's
lightsaber was read in the original Star
Wars trilogy and he was like well good
guys Blue bad guys red that's just the
way it works
that was his explanation back in the 70s
it's just because that's the way it is
I guess our brains are just programmed
to accept things that way now all that
craziness aside they did confirmed that
the back half of the season is going to
zero in on the zoom plot it's gonna get
more and more intense until they have
their final battle we'll learn more
about zoom hopefully each episode I'm
not expecting every single episode but
if we're gonna be seeing scenes from the
reverse flashes perspective expect to
get the same treatment for zoom what
more scenes with zoom interacting with
other people when the flash isn't around
in related news if you guys didn't know
there is a new round of the reverse
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video because of
all the trailers that are gonna drop
tomorrow there's gonna be Suicide Squad
Wonder Woman all announced the first
winner whenever I post that Suicide
Squad trailer I think that'll be the
first video to drop so why you guys wait
for that stuff to post you can click
here for my last flash video and you can
click here for the Game of Thrones
Season 6 teaser that I just posted thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight